get ready for some crash zoom Dutch
angles maybe a cameo by Ted Raimi Bruce
Campbell on top of that and perhaps
perhaps hopefully hopefully an
appearance by Tobey Maguire ooh in
Doctor Strange multiverse of madness now
that Sam Raimi has pretty much
officially confirmed I'm saying pretty
much underline that okay you'll get your
confirmation when you fix this damn door
there's some news here about Sam Raimi
we'll read the whole quote per
traditional YouTube fashion we'll talk
about some of our once desires that we
hope he does with it and also what I
want him to do with Jake Gyllenhaal has
Mysterio in this no one's really talking
about it but I had my reasons as to why
I think to be a cool idea just a
personal thing let's read it
so Sam Raimi was speaking with
comingsoon.net here's what he had to say
I loved Doctor Strange as a kid that's
how he talks by the way but he was
always after spider-man and Batman for
me he was probably number five for me of
great comic book characters he was so
original but when we had that moment in
spider-man 2 I had no idea that we would
ever be making a Doctor Strange movie so
it was really funny to me that
coincidentally that line was in the
movie I got to say I wish we had the
foresight to know that I was going to be
involved in the project that's so cool
so in case you guys don't know I'm sure
other people have already remind you
about it there is a name drop about
Doctor Strange and trying to come up
with an answer Doc Ock in spider-man 2
great but take it Doctor Strange that's
pretty good what it's taken I think that
he would be a great pick the thing that
I would want Sam Raimi to do is kind of
go back a little bit to you know army of
Darkness kind of days or Evil Dead 2
days unless spider-man that being said I
would love a Tobey Maguire cameo in here
but the thing with scott derrickson
being booted off the movie code due to
creative differences and him especially
at Comic Con saying he really wanted to
capitalize on the horror
even though keeping the pg-13 make it
more horrific it seems like that's
probably not gonna be the case which is
a bummer because I think Sam Raimi
providing some of that whimsical zany
level of madness horror would be
fantastic for the multiverse of madness
as it stands you know it's like it's
been a while since we've had like a big
Sam Raimi film and I imagine he's
probably just gonna end up doing his own
thing and then from every little leak or
just the title knowing what the concept
is of Doctor Strange multiverse of
madness I can imagine that he he won't
feel like he needs to really follow
stylistically or tonally what the first
Doctor Strange was I imagine he's gonna
be able to do a lot of whatever he
really wants to do that being said
Marvel does work from the top down
primarily so you know it's like you got
your Sam Raimi films like drag me to
hell where he's do whatever the hell he
wants and you got like oz the great and
powerful
let's hope it's somewhere in the middle
there yeah yeah this is really
interesting to me because of all these
situations and because of where Marvel
is at now because they do represent a
very fascinating push pulled to me and
this project in and of itself kind of
encapsulates that so on the one hand I'm
really excited about this news partly
because it makes sort of a redemption
for Sam Raimi with Marvel specifically
because we all know spider-man 3 did not
go down how kind of anybody wanted it to
to have him back is a great idea he's
perfectly suited to a project like this
and even though yeah we can't expect it
to be as horror as maybe a lot of us
would like I feel like his edge
especially if you count movies like army
of Darkness that which is very much
comedy first in a lot of ways I think he
can really access something about this
universe and and make it his own without
it feeling too foreign because Doctor
Strange is already so out there and
already has a lot of world twisting and
to your point before about working in
Jake Gyllenhaal Mysterio somehow I don't
know how it would happen but I think it
could be really cool because in two very
opposite ways they're both masters of
illusion you know and masters of magic
and so yeah this seems like way to start
stealing some of what I teased that I
said I was going to talk about later
John I'm so just harping on the point I
set up a structure here of what we
wanted and that may talking about
spider-man and now your opposite race am
i Mysterio what if he gets a cameo from
James Frank or a for Kirsten day or
yeah I'm just this seems like a great
idea and if Marvel is like it seems like
dr. strange in the multiverse of madness
is gonna be important for setting up a
lot of the structure of what's to come
from all the speculations so while that
worries me in a committee sense I do
think that Kevin Feige and marble do
relish in letting filmmakers have carte
blanche over as much as they can and I
feel like there is plenty of room for
Sam Raimi to make a Marvel movie with
his soul in it well I think what Sam
Raimi can do is totally provide a lot I
think that's something that he doesn't
get enough credit for is he can mix in
all kinds of tones and this wonderful
piece of most of the time it doesn't
feel messy yeah but sometimes it does
but most of the time he can have like a
lot of heart
he could have horror elements he could
have adventure action he could have
romance he could do it like spider-man
pure fun I hear a comedy peer at comic
book spider-man - I think encompasses
pretty much all of that I think like
multiverse of madness what are you going
to want to do is like you use the phrase
once of calling it like the train
station for all these stores they're
gonna be opening cuz I think you can
even have like a Deadpool cameo in here
to open up the door for that I think Sam
Raimi could work a Deadpool cameo in
here but we're hopping into multiverses
and I think for the Tobey Maguire thing
that a lot of people are hoping they
they implement in this film I want to be
opposed to it and I think that they
could do is maybe like 10 minutes it
doesn't have to be a major plot point
like a 5 to 10 minute sequence somehow
that I mean yeah has to naturally fit in
in some way there could even be shorter
than that I'm thinking a little bit more
like how Days of Future past x-men ended
were like oh they fixed some stuff yeah
some stuff up because the way spider-man
3 and it didn't have a true resolve
especially with Peter Parker and Mary
Jane so you can kind of hop into a
different dimension of that spider-man
world and then just kind of quickly see
what they're up to do you know like I'm
they're married and maybe they have a
kid or like he's old man spider-man I
don't know it's super easy for him
because now everyone thinks it's this
other Peter Parker so he doesn't even
have to hide him this is easy because
Tom Hollands taken the rap because of
Jay Jones James way speculate
that's confusing though because that's a
different dimension though I'm Holly
what if he's also in this dimension who
knows the posture the reason I would
think would be cool to do a like a a
jake gyllenhaal Mysterio cameo or
something that helps set up for another
movie there is a point in time where
Jake Gyllenhaal was going to be
spider-man when there was like
negotiation issues or the speculation
goes there's negotiation issues toad
McGuire for spider-man 2 or he had a
back injury or it was a little bit of
both Jake Gyllenhaal was the one who was
primarily being courted to replace Tobey
Maguire my introduction to Mysterio and
and I think it's the way it goes in the
comics but at least in the animated show
was Mysterio was posing as spider-man
though I think you could do something
kind of cool like an bad and then reveal
oh you know that Quentin Beck have was
like posing as spider-man at one point
yeah yeah it's like an homage to that
point to that uh to that thing
especially you know like I don't I just
think that it's like a real-life Easter
Egg yeah real life Easter Egg
meta-commentary and so I think having
like a Deadpool reference and there
wouldn't be bad I think there's a lot
you can do and I think for what they're
trying to achieve and Nick's into this
film I think Sam rain is the perfect fit
because like I said he can't only
balance a hell of a lot oh yeah and and
if there's one thing that we can say for
certain is that this will be hands-down
the grossest MCU movie who's gonna cover
Doctor Strange and slime a few times
yeah bugs or something cuz it just seems
like he loves to do that yeah and yeah
and then I'm sure he'll do a good job
you know with Wanda and strange as well
all right guys what do you think of this
news of Sam Raimi pretty much confirming
that he is going to be directing Doctor
Strange what are you hoping that he does
with it what's signature snap are you
hoping that really shines in this film
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
click the bell for more and last but not
least
for Eric and Tuesday are very dear
friend Erica I wrote you a little
something
Erica Tuesday I'll shout you out on a
Wednesday for any day would be a blue
day without Erica Tuesday
move over tacos this is Erica's day
don't want no twofers unless it's
Erica's way wouldn't you say that Ms
Tuesday is the best damn patron in the
US of A I mean I would although I
suppose you could say insinuate state
some other name to claim that
illustrious title in place but then to
you I would say nay because much like
Highlander there can be only one
Erica Tuesday and Erica much love to you
just wanted to break the fourth wall
really quick and be sincere you're
fantastic and I don't know actually how
much I can say about this but Eric is
working on some pretty awesome animated
material right now that I hope you all
get to see at some point soon cuz it's
gonna be pretty friggin rad so thanks
for being you thanks for being the
wonderful warm compassionate gigantic
hearted unique individual that you are
and we'll talk soon much love dear what